automatic might be the most underrated
cs go player in north america on
skadoodle watching long
automatically he's like hey i saw what
you did last round i want to do the same
thing automatic now wants the ace it's
team on who's now watching through the
window and jesus christ automatic just
gives him a haircut he's got the results
the stats and the skills to be
considered one of the best players in
the world
cloud9 answering back twice as hard
taking down kelly automatic with the
kill and just like that clown nine in a
one versus four
taco can't do anything the pandemonium
is 16 rounds and cloud9 are in the grand
finals of a major tournament i mean it's
still technically the weaker site to go
to although snappy oh
i want to spin from automatic a huge
kill i think they saw him as kind of
like the swiss army knife where he was
going to plug all the holes all the gaps
that they were missing as a team already
but despite being one of the hardest
working pros in the game somehow
automatic lost everything and was forced
to leave the game he loved behind it's
just tim's just lacking some game
knowledge a little bit
just a little bit just a just a teeny
tiny bit
oh
no
now after a year of struggling automatic
is back looking for glory once more and
those who didn't give him the chance he
deserved might live to regret it he's
gonna be jumping up showing his little
head there's one he does find it and now
they start to cross into his crosshair
automatic with the second and he's gonna
light up another round for us with this
orb he's on a third there's just no
stopping him
terrorists
can't even do it with his own awp and
that's around for automatic for himself
[Applause]
all right folks before we get into the
video i just want to remind you all to
please sub to the channel and turn on
notifications if you haven't done it yet
because it really does help we are super
close to 2 million subs and you could be
the one who gets us there now automatic
started his cs career at a very young
age by the time he was 15 he was
competing in esea events for
counter-strike source and once cs go
came out automatic worked his way
through the n a scene crossing paths
with players like cemphus heco and many
more and that's i mean the question is
might even walk at that point because
it's gonna be obvious that you're coming
it's more about when you get inside the
site does put the smoke out nothing
can't find it so far nothing can't find
it so far this is a full 10 second
defuse and nothing thinks he's off it
automatic is about to get a ninja or is
the knife gonna get him he does
unfreaking believable eventually
automatic made it to the big leagues he
was signed by tsm and earned a top four
finish at ecs season one
again will do dirty work but it is
automatic and then dramatic again more
importantly though tim's performance
made other orgs take notice he was a
hard worker and his skill was undeniable
and automatic's years of hard work
finally paid off when he was recruited
by stewie2k to join the team that would
change his life
well you can see all the flashbangs as
well connecting in the
around oh man
looking for a phone
with a beautiful pistol
automatic's time on cloud nine started
off red hot he carried the team to
victory against one of the best teams in
the world at esl pro league season four
and was named mvp for his performance in
a one versus one and he's got no idea
where automatic is he's rotated all the
way to long
and cold might get caught he's looking
down toward the door he's in the open
it's automatic to give cloud9 season
four the the only bigger rise than
stewie is perhaps automatic like where
did this guy come from because he's been
in the scene for for two years i'd say
and he's been like a kind of like a
journeyman a journeyman role player on a
couple different rosters um and then all
of a sudden he comes on this team and we
see this the superstar like we always
saw the skill but we figured after two
years of seeing him in these teams you
kind of knew what you were gonna get and
i think he's shocked everyone i mean
everyone no one expected this kind of a
level from him over the next year c9
built a reputation as a team that
demanded respect sure they were never
the best team in the world but with win
after win they were building a fanbase
it is gonna be automatic taking point
will he find a shot there's the peak and
there's the shot to open it up simple
it's gone and again so we're in a 1v1
potentially to decide the tournament
keep
gentlemen
[Applause]
but it's not enough it's a double hop up
for renegades and skadoodle he'll make
it work nifty dead as well and that's it
cloud nine ladies and gentlemen we'll be
your victors here at the i buy power
masters 2017. and sure during 2017 no
one could deny that it was the stewie
show he was an all-star talent and
earned mvp at both events c91 that year
but meanwhile automatic was proving
himself as one of the most consistent
players out there with some of the best
adr and kpr stats on the team automatic
showed up when it mattered most unlike
with other players he doesn't seem like
a star player but if you look at the
statistics it shows he is over towards
beat two out toward oh automatic i was
going to stay up to work
and automatic finds in third is sk have
full control
or do they oh my goodness automatic four
hp
mine's two kills it's all for not
perhaps or is it because skadoodle's
actually going on undetected they put so
much effort
oh my god automatic automatic as a ump
how much can you really get out of this
position if you're automatic he's a
shadow that advantage is very helpful
another one from automatic unbelievable
stuff there going with the ak pickup for
another one third kill coming in and
he's looking to basically win the round
by himself audi goes perfect flash
perfect finish automatic saves the day
but in 2018 everything changed for
automatic heading into the boston major
cloud nine were certified underdogs but
they went on to have one of the most
incredible tournament runs in esports
history patiently as cloud9 sets the
push up
oh always happens they made it work
clown nine are your league major
champions
everything came together for cloud 9 in
boston every player had moments of
brilliance tarik gave a standout
performance and became the tournament's
mvp but he wasn't in a league of his own
statistically speaking automatic wasn't
far behind
[Applause]
shuts down kenny and now he's got apex
pushing there's another one a second for
automatic and stewie's gonna make his
move now
trying to take advantage of the rotation
and that shot just nearly misses
something needs to change here playing
very carefully mbk very aggressive this
is good news
for g2 by automatic again
it's going to be a peak out of the oven
he sees it all domestic gets the triple
kill saves the round and resets sk
gaming and automatic putting a lot of
pressure on here in the middle he's
gonna get one killer headshot
the delay grenade there but it's too
late stewie picking it up
that tournament run propelled every
player on the team to start him but it's
hard to overstate just how important
automatic was to c9's success in boston
you see automatic is what you call a
high impact player wherever you needed
him most automatic was there getting
critical opening kills or even clutching
out maps but just as automatic reached
the peak of the cs world
everything collapsed
shortly after the major stu ended up
leaving and joining mibr and then a few
months later
tariq ended up leaving and joining mibr
and then tyler ended up retiring
and then it was just me
rush and valens
and
yeah for the last year and a half we've
been trying to rebuild
and get back to
to that level and it's been really tough
eventually all that was left of the
roster was rush and automatic c9 tried
experimenting with non-na talent but
nothing worked for the next year c9
bombed out of almost every big
tournament however despite all that
automatic was popping off in fact he
might have been playing some of the best
cs of his career it sort of feels like
that could be happening
oh that's a beautiful shot second
headshot one more coming in taking down
kerrigan on point right now with the
desert eagle the deagle to take down all
the questions oh my god automatic
flashes as well automatic tries to hold
and he will successfully and the trace
folds all the way to the ground but then
steps up finds cold he's looking for an
ace in automatics got all five the bomb
is planted one hp on automatic that
smoke could save him that's the ak
automatic has the headshot potential the
smoke could not only save him but give
him an escape and taco is aware of it it
could be back-to-back halves in which sk
steal back round two he's giving a lot
of time away to automatic who's staying
with us
quite good throughout 2018 automatic
picked up the highest rating on his team
at nine separate events as well as 4 evp
awards and the 17 spot on hltv's top 20
list he was the only player from the
major winning c9 roster to make that
list by 2019 people felt kind of bad for
automatic he was clearly an incredible
player and the community respected his
dedication loyalty and commitment to
making c9 competitive but at some point
he just had to put himself first it
definitely doesn't feel the same anymore
for me and
i feel like it's time
for me to have a change in my life and
and i just want to thank all the fans
for supporting me throughout all these
years and in december those fans finally
got their wish automatic left c9 to join
gen g 14 liquid it's stewie lands a an
incredible shot there onto the player
getting out of apps it's all left on to
automatically oh okay
and stewie automatic down to the 1v1
just twists left to beat he touched the
bomb
and automatic with three he's gonna be
jumping up showing his little head
there's one he does find it and now they
start to cross into his crosshair
automatic with the second and he's gonna
light up another round for us with this
four he's on a third there's just no
stopping him
can't even do it with his own awp and
that's around for automatic this second
map has not made sense from the
beginning of the round and and now it's
automatic and so he's just trading
back and forth yeah he's on for it
he should have never gotten some of
these kills but automatic timothy tatas
takes all five
but automatic stint with genji didn't
last the team fell off a cliff when
coveted hit sending csgo into an online
era and genji into irrelevance everyone
assumed automatic would just sign with a
new team but he never did and you're
probably asking yourself if automatic
was still putting up numbers why were
tier 1 orgs just not interested in him
why were they passing up a major winning
top 20 player you see around this time
nacs as a whole was dying teams that
didn't already move to europe for access
to better online tournaments and
practice opponents soon would later the
majority of any orgs pulled out of cs
altogether leaving tim without a lot of
options but it wasn't just automatic
there were plenty of pros in the same
situation and for many who couldn't find
a new team to join in counter-strike
there's only one option left
valorant but when you're entering in
this game there's so much
and
[Music]
you don't have as many flashes to work
with
and there's a lot of counter play
so you got to be aware of all that so
it's kind of hard you have to have your
routes really
your routes and your rolls really well
thought out i think automatic held out
longer than most but the writing was on
the wall his longtime mentor dazed
convinced him to give valor in the shot
and eventually he made the switch in
february 2021 automatic joined skadoodle
on t1's valerian roster unfortunately
the transition wasn't exactly smooth
i feel like this game is hardest
it's not killing people it's actually
killing all these random objects in the
game
like killing drones killing roombas
killing darts dodging silva olds dodging
results it's like the hardest
tim simply didn't look comfortable
invalid he tried his best to embrace it
and grind it away on stream but
it just never took it's skadoodle he
falls last one's out of it he's found
himself a double 1v2 now
still needs to get the defuse moving
quickly
tries to talk about the stakes when he
comes over the top it sums again for the
final kill
and sentinels move on t1 eliminated from
stage two of the vct it didn't help the
t1 was a disaster they didn't make it to
a single land event all year and by
august there were no major tournaments
left for them to compete in tim seemed
done with all of it
for a while i wasn't planning on
switching to valorant
but then
the head coach of t1 david he uh
asked me if i wanted to play for him and
i'd work with him i've worked with him
for a long time so
i was like okay let's do it and then
here we are
losing two qualifiers
tim just didn't look happy playing
valorent and why would he think about it
tim had to leave the game he loved for
what he must have felt like was a
knockoff and he still ended up playing
with a team that couldn't perform time
and time again he made it clear just how
much he missed cs i mean not saying that
i don't like ballarat but
yes it's just home you know luckily for
automatic and his fans the star is
eventually aligned cs made its way out
of the online era and a lot of teams
started to shuffle their rosters a bit
to challenge the new gods of the game
viewership crept back up and all of a
sudden cs was more popular than ever
which meant that na orgs had budgets to
go start signing players again so
finally after over a year of what many
felt like was a waste of his potential
automatic dumped valorent and returned
to cs go this time to play for evil
geniuses alongside his former teammates
stewie and rush got a player deep long a
but everybody's just so coloneled like
this a push of both sides automatic
three frags on the anti-eco now to be
fair eg aren't exactly dominating at the
level you'd expect given their pedigree
but it's still really early for this
roster and there's a lot more
counter-strike to play these days than
there was in the last few years but for
now automatic is back playing the game
he loves and he's made it clear that
he's ready to make it work so it could
be kind of intimidating i think to come
back and it didn't look like he was
intimidated so that's a really great
sign i messaged him off the game i said
you're back and he said not yet
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock